i didn't see him for a while then one
day i got home i found my mother dead
and even though i didn't see him for a
while he was the first one there that
morning
you know and he talked to me and we went
we took all her jewelry out of porn and
we we [__] got the the the cemetery
all hooked up and the the undertaker and
the [__]
funeral parlor and there was a cuban
funeral parlor so they [__] keep you
for five days
now some people bury after two [__] that
cubans and it's 24 7.
there's no two to four and four to seven
[__] you cubans like to go out and come
and drink and sit with the body at night
creepy [__] but
so we had shifts we had shifts it was 24
hours it was me
in the daytime my my stepdad in the
afternoon and my uncle from california
would do the 12th day shift and i'd hang
out with him sometimes because there was
no school that week
and the night before my mother got
buried it was a sunday night and it was
just me and my stepdad in the room and
he goes come here for a second
he goes i went to the house last week
and i went up in the attic
and i was looking for something and i
found this in the room he went in his
back pocket
he found the baggie full of roaches and
guys he looked at me and as he was
looking at me i could see the tears in
his eyes
he goes is this yours and again
you know no it's not mine
dog i found it upstairs is this yours
and he goes do me a favor
swear in front of your mother right now
you'll never smoke pot again
because you can't do that because you
just can't do that and i told them i
can't i can't swear in front of my
mother i don't know if i'm ever going to
smoke pot again
so he was kind of upset about it and
then he goes listen i want you to do me
a favor
my mother had died i could either move
to california i could move to miami or i
could move with him
you know my dad lived a life he lived on
the fourth he was he was always hiding
he always hit his money from the cops so
he lived in an apartment on the fourth
floor with no elevator
i'm not gonna move into that [__]
building you know it was on 18th street
that means at night i had to go out and
take a bus all the way down there
so at the funeral he goes listen dawg my
whatever's mine is yours
he goes i'd like for you to come live
with me he goes i'll give you the
bedroom you go to school i'll take care
of you
you can work the flower shop in the
afternoon make yourself some money
i looked him straight in the face and i
go no i go i can't do it i'm moving in
with a friend of mine because he
was he wanted me to be in at 11 o'clock
i was a sophomore in high school
i had no curfew and the friends i hung
out with had no [__] curfew how am i
going to change my life
now to come home at 11 o'clock and have
to do homework every night i was my own
[__] man by that time already it was
just me and my mom for two years
i did my own laundry my own everything i
cooked i did everything
me and her so how can i go live with
this guy and that was it that just
[__] destroyed him when i said that
to him as a father he's like so you're
not going to come live with me to go
live
with your friends and i go that's right
i got to go do this it's in north bergen
i'm around my friends and he's like all
right
you know i can't think about what that
guy felt like
i can't even think about it because no
matter who he shot no matter how [__]
crazy he was he loved me
and he taught me how to be a man he took
me from day one and taught me you know
after my mother died dog you know i went
into a spiral i was living with this guy
his brother was a cop and every night
this guy's brother would come in and
tell me about what he heard on the radio
about what was going on in west new york
about what was going on with drugs or
fighting or shooting
and he would come home and he would tell
me the [__] one night he goes your
father got arrested tonight
he goes two people tried to mug him he
took the gun off one of them shot the
one guy and he shot the other guy
he killed the one i mean this is when he
was 55 by this time he was 50 [__]
five
but he was shooting people and getting
away with it because it was self-defense
he was a millionaire by this time
and people try to rob him at night and
he [__] blast him another night
he was in new york city with somebody
and there was a shootout and the guy got
shot he put him in the car with him the
guy died in his car
but he died in the car as he was going
over the lincoln tunnel so he threw the
gun out when he got out of the lincoln
tunnel they pulled him over they had the
cameras
and he beat that he had an attorney that
would be [__] anything he didn't
shoot the guy he was just helping his
friend out
but that was the life style he had you
know and i would hear this [__] i'm like
this [__] is getting crazy here
i am doing eight balls
you know robbing people but this
motherfucker's really going crazy he's
stabbing people and shooting people by
that time at the funeral
we had this family friend that we go to
baseball games with and i guess they had
a misunderstanding and he had sliced his
ass one night
and at the [__] funeral he had to
apologize because the guy was a family
friend of my mother's
at the funeral they had a hug and
apologized that's how crazy he got
after what happened with him and my
mother and after you know then later on
with the death
me and him went at it because my mother
left the house she left property where
miami international was she left jewelry
and he kept saying you're on your own
[__] and i'm like i want half my
mother's money
so i kept [__] going back and forth
and i kept going all my criminal buddies
their parents and going go talk to this
[__] guy
you know some of my friends were parents
with mafia guys i could go talk to them
and get my [__] money back
and they're like joey we can't talk to
this guy we don't want no problems this
[__] guy this guy got a reputation as
a killer
you're on your [__] home there was a
time in my life like when i was 20
if i was gonna kill this guy i'm like
i'm gonna go by by his house and hide
under a car
and shoot him that was never gonna
happen this guy would see me coming a
[__] mile away
a mile away he'd see me coming i was
such a [__] amateur
you know what i was upset i loved him
and i felt like he was stealing from me
and one day i started thinking about i'm
like you know what man here i am sitting
here
like a spoiled little [__] crying about
this money i'm gonna get [__] this money
i'm gonna go get my own [__] money
i'm gonna go live my own [__] life
you know here i am sitting here telling
people getting coked up going
in three years i'm gonna get a half a
million dollars i wasn't gonna get
nothing
there was nothing coming to me he wasn't
gonna give me nothing until this day you
gotta think what if he would have gave
me thirty thousand dollars i would have
blown in a day
at that time i wouldn't have done
nothing good with it you know
so we didn't talk we stopped talking in
1985 we didn't talk again until 91
i went to colorado and talked to him for
six years came back in 91.
i went to see him man and he was very
apprehensive by this time i had tried to
rob his partner
i [__] uh i i fronted an ounce from
his nephew and never paid him and he
would hear about all these things
and all these things would break his
heart little by little and i remember
pulling up one day and i got out of the
car and i go before you say something
i got locked up in prison i did time i
go everything you said i was going to do
i did you're [__] right you know you
were right if i would have moved in with
you i would have grown up to be a better
man
i go i'm here now you know and i wasn't
by no means was i ready for this guy
i was still snorting blow and mugging
people i was still a [__] mess
and he was trying to be my father he's
like really you have a wife now i hope
you're doing better
he asked me about prison how was it did
you like it yeah i liked it no i didn't
[__] like it
he started telling me about his prison
stories how he was in jail with [__]
crazy gallow and all this [__]
and we kept we got tighter over the
years like night from 94
on i would go to new york twice a year
and i'd go buy a pound or two of shrimp
and he'd cook for me and we
have conversations and [__] and then i
got into
you know doing movies and comedy let me
tell you something this [__] guy was
an insomniac and one night he's up
and he sees the sopranos and he's he's
big [__] he thinks it's me right so he
told everybody he called cuba oh my god
jose antonio's on the mafia show oh my
god i'm
so is his hit
[Laughter]
his wife called me one day she's like is
that you and i go no and she's like
don't say nothing to him
cause he thinks it's you and he'll break
his heart dog i've never seen him this
proud even put your picture back
up and [__] right
so i'm like come on really you know and
it just started dawning on me all the
pain i brought to this guy's life for no
[__] reason
no reason at all all this guy was ever
trying to do is be my father
you know and that's that's the funny
thing about fathers that i was thinking
about
listen man you can have all the problems
in your life you want anything i had a
thousand problems
but the biggest problem i had the
biggest obstacle that was stopping me to
do anything in my life
was not claiming responsibility i wrote
about it this week because it's big man
i talk to people all the time
you know i work with comedians and they
get off stage the crowd sucks dog
did you ever think that maybe you sucked
you know all the sound was shitty well
as a professional you know
it's going up so you have to either yell
louder anything
and you know those people we all know
like what happened last night i couldn't
make a dog
you know i couldn't find the keys to my
car just tell me you got [__] up
just tell me i got [__] up and didn't
want to hang out but don't come to me
with that excuse
for years even after i went to prison i
thought i had it down but i was never
claimed it was always somebody else's
fault
you know what happened oh [__] that
[__] didn't call me so i missed my job
what the
some lady's supposed to call you and
wake you up you're a [__] grown man
and that's what juan was trying to teach
me all those years you know wash that
dish
pick up that [__] underwear you know
claim responsibility these are the
things you have to do is
i blame myself for everything now that's
how bad i've gotten to the point if
there's an accident on 134
if i get up at 6 30 and i'm watching
ktla but i really do
just to see what traffic is and there's
an accident 134 i blame myself
i'm like that was me last night i must
have swerved and the guy got off i swear
to god
because no because it's a [__] thing
i couldn't move forward
and in all those years that juan listen
as crazy as he was this guy never laid a
hand on me
never even grabbed me by the throat or
nothing
nothing he was a gentle dude when it
came to me
it was everybody else he [__] hated
everybody else you've watched godfather
the guy with the big dick that they go
see
in cuba there's a scene where he's tied
up and the guy's got a big dick
and that's when al pacino rats out fredo
fredo took me here and al pacino [__]
turns bail
that guy with the big [__] dick he
had like a two foot [__] dick a cuban
guy
he had a son that had a big dick too
right i swear to god and the club's name
was club 38 on union city
and every friday the guy would show his
dick on stage a chick would come up and
they'd [__] shove it in her mouth
and she'd choke and cry you got to see
this [__] [__] classic
so he did numbers with the owner of the
bar you know this is how crazy he was
i was a kid i was like nine and what he
would do at night was take me with him
on collections
he will come on get in the car let's go
eat an ice cream but what he was really
doing
was i was like blocking for him you know
and i remember one night i go in i'm
like 12 he's like come here you got to
see this
this guy had a robe on his dick was down
to his knees it was dead
it was dead like it was like pissed dead
like it was down with [__] knees and
i'm like
touching my own dick like what do i got
to do to make your dick that big but the
guy
the guy didn't have his money i remember
that the guy didn't have his money and
[__]
and he started talking to the guy like
what am i gonna have my money but the
guy's like hey juan
i'll give you the money when you get it
and i thought juan was gonna shoot this
[__] this is how cool he was
he was like really and he had a pen over
here i thought it was a pen it was a
[__]
gas gun like one of those things you
[__] shoot pepper spray in somebody's
face
and he's like really no [__] he looks
like he goes cover your eyes he takes
the pen out he just shoots the guy in
the chest with it the guy starts holding
his eyes the whole club was coughing and
[__]
me and him just walk out boy that was a
close call that's the kind of [__] he
did with me in the car
that's the kind of [__] and i will and i
loved it he would say don't say nothing
to your mother
because your mother won't accept that
[__] i'm gonna say what am i a crime
stop i don't give a [__]
i wanna see you stab people dog
so it was really weird like i put all
that stuff together you know
while we were watching like it took me
[__] two minutes
to see what happened with me and this
guy while i was watching that stupid
longest yard movie
and how proud he was and there was parts
where his lip was moving because he was
gonna [__] cry
you know that's what he did for me that
was he was my man so
just do me a favor bro do two things for
me if you got a problem with your dad or
something
that's all they wanted us to do even if
your father was drunk and he [__] say
[__] to you
he wanted us to be better men than he
was i never [__] knew this [__] man i
wish somebody would have [__] told me
i never knew this i never knew what
manhood entailed
you could have a big dick you could [__]
a thousand women that's got nothing to
do with manhood
it's claiming responsibility and after
you do that
it's like stealing it's like stealing
nothing else [__] bothers you
and i'm sitting there looking at this
[__] at the end this is 2006.
and he's like boy that was a good movie
and i'm like i thought it sucked
but whatever he was like i'm really
proud of you and all this stuff and at
the end of the conversation i'll tell
you how hard this [__] was
it was 2006 and i go to him remember the
night you shot nico and he goes
i don't know what you're talking about
and that's that's what i'm talking about
guys
and i looked at him i was ready to say
like and i go oh this [__]
so just just do me that favor that's all
he wanted to do he just wanted me to
grow up to be a [__] man
that's all he was doing all those years
by telling me all that [__] and today
i live by my life it turns out sometimes
the guy you hate is the guy you end up
[__] becoming
you know and that's what i've learned in
his life like that's why this testicle
testament was important to me i hope
it's important to you
because i learned something from that
whole lesson no matter how bad of a
[__] guy he was with people how
he never touched my mother all those
stories that night when my mother
blasted him in the [__] head
he was hesitant he just wanted to grab
her and maybe smack her one time
which is acceptable when somebody breaks
a [__] same thing in your head
when you're [__] sleeping you know
what i'm saying but uh
i got a picture of him now and i look at
it whenever i'm down and it just
toughens me up because that's all he
ever wanted
you know was just to toughen me up like
i said i look at guys now you look at
somebody and they got like a cute
[__]
attitude to them with flip-flops on and
they think they're cool
and you know that if the world ended
these [__] couldn't survive
that was me
you know if my mother wouldn't have died
30 years ago i would have been a [__]
half a fruitcake right now
i would have been soft i would have been
short because my mother was spoiling me
she was rich
and she gave me whatever the [__] i
wanted and all juan was trying to do
was to balance that out and to say you
can't give him everything he wants
that's the worst thing
you know who broke the window my son
would never break the window yes he
[__] would
i seen him with the bb gun breaking
[__] windows
you know so it did me no good and all
that that piece of grove him yelling at
me
and saying those things and i could be
up here going my
my stepfather stopped me from [__] you
that's for [__]
your stepfather wanted you your father
wanted you to be a man
so don't ever be mad at your father just
please work with me on this one and
number two
claim responsibility you don't give a
[__] i did it what [__]
what are you gonna do throw me in
[__] jail what are you gonna do
and it's funny because when i got thrown
in jail that's what the judge told me he
goes the reason why i'm throwing you in
jail is
he goes you'll never get in trouble
again but you didn't claim
responsibility i thought claim and
responsibility was being a rat
it's not it's just going this is who the
[__] i
am i'm happy you guys came out tonight
man uh
thank you thank you from the bottom of
my heart all right
i'll see you [__] outside let's
do this
[Applause]
you